thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone to another amazing
episode of the careful boys we have with
us today Mr Hans Kim hey
[Applause]
for this hot tea episode the way that it
goes is that we progressively ask you
questions by your life could be anything
but we start really easy and then as we
go we get a little more personal a
little more intrusive uh I feel like
you're gonna have no problem because
you're pretty comfortable with uh being
put on the spot so we're gonna start
easy with
one of you guys can do it so yeah we're
gonna start with a cold question welcome
to Hot Seat the show with the hottestine
he always
version
the most coldest question ever and it's
ice cold we try to get people to click
away as fast as we can so cold steel so
what's what's your favorite letter that
starts with a
[Laughter]
survival Good Start yeah another
question I have is how many genders are
there at least five at least okay
can you can you dive in deeper about
that which which five male female uh
Spirit gender Spirit uh this Native
American
uh no gender
half male yeah right half female oh
that's at least five yeah you left
halfling but it's fine yeah I can't
believe you forgot that how did you feel
about flaming hot Cheetos
I'm not a fan oh are they flaming hot is
that the problem they're not hot enough
for their taxes yeah we hate flamers I
see
you voted you bought against them as
much as you can yeah you're not allowed
to get married if you're a flaming hot
cheetah are you a Takis guy is that
really what's going on maybe
he's a blue Takis kind of guy your blue
Takis guy Fuego yeah I like the celkang
uh Korean little crackers
what was the last joke you said on stage
that you got booed for
um probably that uh communism should be
given another shot
who are you what city were you in uh
Comedy Store
damn yeah but isn't communism getting
another shot like there's China there's
a couple places yeah it's a research
there's a Los Angeles maybe that's why
they booed you because it's like that's
not accurate it's getting a show yeah
we're doing fine boo we're in it we're
represented who uh how many girls did
you bang in Georgia Tech
uh zero oh 0.0 like no over the close
things or yeah yeah not even close not
even a kiss I had to graduate and do an
internship and then I met a girl at a
Georgia Tech party and then I kissed and
I had sex with her for the first time
yeah that's cool in your life
I mean that was the first time you lost
you lost it I thought you said it was
the first time you had sex with her
was it magical
it was all right I like your body
language right now it's really nervous
it's good it's good what would make that
experience better because you said it
was all right uh if uh she was more
attractive
that's honest answer hey we never [ __ ]
the tens initially we never we never
started [ __ ] the tents you gotta earn
you gotta work your way up geez you
gotta level up and what would happen
more attractive to you
uh
classical Beauty you know maybe
maybe way less than me
yeah that's big actually well she's big
but that's big too that's cool Beauty
when he said that I was picturing
[ __ ] Beethoven and [ __ ] where do you
think it's like one of those situations
where you're like man okay like if she
gets on top of me they're gonna have to
call the fire department no not that bad
okay she was still away it was hard to
maneuver a little bit okay
[Laughter]
what's the funniest female comedian to
you uh Maria Bamford oh she's really
funny she's very funny we like her yeah
she's crazy her favorite your favorite
brand of Manford joke
what about the office like where she's
like I know this girl at the office
hates me because she'll tell anyone
anything but she won't tell me it and
she's like my cat is so intuitive like
looks back at me it's like what what are
you looking at it's like you know what
you did and then Maria Bamford is like I
want to hear this story about the cat
why can't you tell me
uh but yeah I love it when she does it
yeah
[Laughter]
you ever done any drugs yeah which kinds
Molly meth uh uh at the same time you're
a meth guy huh I've done it once when
was was it High School it was a little
jittery hey your hardcore is [ __ ] it
like last year oh yeah what was the
occasion I was in Tucson Arizona that
sounds like a mess Town yeah your
nephew's birthday party did someone like
offer it to you or was it yeah it was
like this comic that lives in a trailer
and he's like I do math it's something
that I do and I was like well I'm always
down for a good sesh yeah little smoke
sesh okay so we just took a little toke
and then went to do an open mic
I bet energy just went a little bit up
man it was it was good it was like I was
a little jittery
it was a little fast you think it was
the math
maybe it wasn't and how do you think
you're set with I thought it went all
right
I didn't connect with the audience as
much as I wanted to they weren't I think
it was yeah what
um what's the craziest thing you've seen
uh when you were living in your van
uh I saw a guy peeing right by my van
and I was like I'm not gonna bother him
let him finish yeah he's more legally in
the right than I am right now
I wanted to tell on you back yeah yeah
did you did you grow up sheltered
a little bit Yeah like was your parents
controlling like you got to be this way
good boy a little bit not too much so
when did you
open yourself up to freedom in college
the drugs that uh had a little gravity
bomb
that's your introduction to we would cut
a two liter or a gallon or something
yeah no classic yeah it was the best you
didn't have to smoke it yourself you
could use the bottle to smoke it for you
and then it was like secondhand smoke
yeah because you don't have to use the
pressure your lungs to suck it out yeah
it was colder because like it takes the
initial heat so you just have a box of
smoke and you just shove it in your
lungs oh yeah
you are you do have a degree in
mechanical engineering I kind of heard
it there
and the way that you described it yeah
yeah I know I heard it yeah I've never
heard anyone yeah I've never heard
anyone explain a gravity bong some level
so when you're a mechanical engineering
right and then at home you go home smoke
your weed and do your comedy thing what
was the breaking point where you're like
I'm not gonna do this anymore
uh mechanical engineering yeah and then
become a full-time comedian what what
what was the pivoting moment was there
like a like a bridge you were like a
model you were building you just
destroyed it one day yeah what were you
like tripping out on meth and we're like
this cinematic symbolism I was just like
I got fired I'm living with my mom oh
you got fired yeah so that does it for
you the internship or from like a job
from a startup company why you get fired
because I was not that good at my job
and then I started arguing with the uh
with the manager
um imagine it was a dick though he was
just insecure
and it was like a small man syndrome oh
yeah those are fun yeah there's a lot of
that going on I'm one of them it's the
eight minute 18 Mark where we turn up
the heat
um you're really good at at taking and
dishing back all manners of Comedy but
has anything actually offended you that
someone said uh yeah I'm sure
um you know uh like sometimes I'll get
offended when people are like you know
uh like you're not funny or like
uh like I had a joke where it's like I
get to use the f word here female and
then this guy was like yeah the only f
word people don't use is funny and I was
like how dare you you're a homo
yeah yeah
he was like ah [ __ ] he's a guy you got
me that was pretty funny [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ]
does anything like does anything racist
actually hit you sometimes so you're
like
yeah like if they're doing it not out of
Good Intentions yeah if they're just
doing it to be like putting me down
instead of like you know like being like
I see you they're like [ __ ] you I'm
gonna ignore you go away or something
like that it's just all of the
intentions like it doesn't matter the
joke it's just like what they want to do
with it how do you respond when you feel
that way like are there any examples of
like what you do when yeah I just try to
critique what I hate the most about that
kind of person and what kind of person
they are and try to incorporate that
into what they just said
Oh you mean like so hecklers you can
destroy them yeah yeah well yeah human a
targeted attack yeah like real life
hecklers
um we've reached the 9 Minute 52 second
one where we have an Asian American Man
review Shang Chi
what'd you think
and what'd you think of seeing you lose
performance
I thought it was a great movie I mean
it's sort of like every other movie
and that genre so I mean I'm not really
a big fan of like I don't think Asians
need a comic book hero to be a
legitimate race
we've done a lot for the world just
would you rather [ __ ] your mom or your
dad and why go in here my dad can take
it better I don't want my mom to be sad
yeah
you're really thinking of the residual
effects the emotions are coming together
none of us has ever done that hesitation
either yeah the one ready to go but but
what if everyone in town starts calling
you Dad [ __ ] what are you doing that's
fine that's way better than a
motherfucker's like Father [ __ ] yeah
you're dead hey here comes the dad
[ __ ] again
better than a pillow [ __ ]
that's a reference
busted too many nuts on it and my mom
had to throw it away today's video is
brought to you by audible so I've been
doing my flights now back and forth from
the Hawaii and they're about a good five
hours and I'm like what can I do for
five hours well I could sleep I could
watch movies I could do a lot of stuff
but audible comes to a lot of awesome
stuff because I could just rest my eyes
and chill this is what I've been
checking out all of my content here I
got good thinking by David Robert Grimes
this is brand new I still haven't
started this one but it's this kind of
cool like graph right and it's and it's
like it goes to like why flawed logic
can lead to like putting us all at risk
and then how critical thinking can save
the world so I've noticed a lot of this
I've noticed like all over the world you
know some groups make great decisions
and then they solve problems in a good
way societal you know all kinds of
issues with the world but there's also
other destructive groups and all that's
different between the two and the only
difference between the two groups is the
decisions that they make how they see
the world and how they critically think
or if they lack critical thinking
so I was like this is really interesting
I want to check that out and I have a
bunch of other books that I just
listened to on the plane now and I like
it better than watching movies sometimes
because a lot of the stuff I get is like
school and learning and I don't go to
college no more and I really miss just
sitting there and listening to somebody
smart that can tell me about the world
yeah in addition to audiobooks Audible
has all kinds of audio entertainment it
got podcasts oh yeah they even got
Originals so they want to be your home
of Storytelling whether it's
storytelling about like fiction
non-fiction how to get better all that
stuff you can go to Audible and you can
get one book per month or one credit per
month and you can listen to either on a
car ride jogging or even on the airplane
it's the home of Storytelling you know
life is all about stories and I love
learning through stories and if you sign
up now it's 30 days for free let audible
help you you discover new ways to laugh
Be Inspired or be entertained new
members can try it free for 30 days
visit audible.com off the Record or text
off the Record to 500-500 that's
audible.com off the Record or text off
the Record to 500-500 to try audible
free for 30 days audible.com off the
record this is the 11 minute
this is the part of the show where we
show you a clip from American American
Cinema history and we get your take on
it and what your thoughts are and most
importantly on it do you like uh Clint
Eastwood I love to see it what what
what's one of your favorite Clint
Eastwood movies yeah uh the one where he
yells at Asian people that was mine too
Gran Torino
[Music]
he is doing that I mean it feels like my
uncle's like right here yeah dude here
we go presenting
a scene
from old enough for kids a JK Rada pack
[Applause]
Ed
13 in September
why did he do that
you know what 10 times out of 10
somebody says why did he do that
you you that was a slow seduction
just do it
do waiting for bro what'd you say weird
[ __ ] just do it you know why because
that whole beginning part it wasn't for
her it was for him for him it's a
virgin's mentality and that calls me
McBee
but that's for context that what he did
wasn't in the script he just did it uh
it's like improv also for context check
out that Jersey what
um like you know what this movie needs
there's a leading woman that's 12.
she wasn't a woman definitely not yeah
yeah and that actor is just like God
damn it yeah yeah that's kind of how it
went yeah yeah yeah and they put it in
the movie yep oh yeah that's a cartoon
classic yeah people said they got a
standing o in the theater yeah
what a Twist yeah yeah thanks for uh
thanks for sharing that you see what
that shirt says right by your head yeah
September
yeah then September 13th oh yeah
I want to put it on it's there for you
yeah but they only if you feel
comfortable what um what's your jumped
into the JK crew welcome I know yeah
you've been inducted what is um what do
you think about the way Pang dang
handled the Tony hitchcliffe stuff I
know I'm not a fan of it uh except for
what it gave me like it created a
horrible sea of confusion and at the end
of it I was a regular on kill Tony so I
think that was great
what do you mean by that like um I
forgot about that what happened again so
uh Pang dang had a set uh and then
introduced Tony hitchcliffe right after
him and then Tony hcliffe uh was
roasting them right after but used some
like coveted stuff some some terminology
you know what I didn't even know the
context to that and I totally misread it
and I was I just thought Tony was some
racist dude that came up and talked [ __ ]
so I didn't know it was a roast thing
well no it's it's not necessarily
roasting it was just a night at a comedy
club but then that's just what he did
and then rather than pengang talking to
him and saying like hey that was [ __ ]
up I didn't like that was weird he just
made a tweet and then put the video out
and then went like that and then all
these people there's like a backlash
over it but really there's different
nuances in how to see that yeah yeah it
was really anti-social it's like we're
all in the same scene we all see each
other and just burned that bridge he
could have just been like yo man that
was too far that was way too far yeah I
mean and that's like a conversation to
be had between two people yeah yeah but
that didn't happen instead he just put
the video out to the public which has no
contacts on how the night felt or any of
that stuff or who said what all they saw
is Tony's
little bits yeah you shouldn't put
anything of someone else out on public
on stage without their permission yeah
that's pretty but isn't the court of
public opinion the ferris Court
not always I mean so how did that play
into how you said that affected your
outcome well yeah after he came back I
did the national anthem I saw that
that's great and then I he was like I'll
give you a set next week I did a set
next week and then and then on that
night he was like do you want to be a
regular
so it all like led into me being a
regular and then he makes every every
like now he makes jokes like oh this is
Hans I brought him so that I could be
uncanceled like this is my uh Olive
Branch the Asian community
hahaha
that's good that's funny speaking of the
age Community
um
who's the uh wax Asian influencer you
know whack is
like just dislike oh [ __ ] you want me to
make an enemy
uh gently [ __ ] you
just kidding no just kidding well he
looks so much older than he is I know
was your first uh impression uh of JK
especially once you got asked to come on
I thought it was amazing yeah I saw the
clips online I was like damn this could
help me get in with the Asian Community
because I feel like most of the kill
Tony fans are just white dudes so I
still have this untapped Market I'm just
here purely for uh my social media
following hell yeah I'm sure to get on
kill Tony dude
we just wanted you here because we want
to get to Joe Rogan
hey we're all using each other well it's
a slow bleed
so no Joe Rogan huh oh yeah so how can
we get on Joe Rogan can you get us all
individually on Joe Rogan or just like
all of us at once that'd be cool you
think he has enough microphones yeah he
does because we saw the fight companions
we know we could all be on Joe we're
going to see a time you get us on there
dude
I feel like if we ever do go on No One's
Gonna talk and everyone's just gonna
stand there and giggle yeah
I don't know and then Jordan was like
what do you guys do I don't know what do
you want us to do we do we do what you
like the city joke yeah do whatever you
want if we do like YouTube and stuff if
you want to do a comedy what would you
be doing
uh like crime
what kind of crime would you have yeah
which guy are you we have we had a
conversation Fair assessment we had a
conversation about this recently like
what position would you play in the
crime team where are you I'd be the guy
in the truck on the computer
he's taking your job man what am I going
to do you're gonna actually
[Laughter]
what's your response to somebody in the
Asian community that asks you to do more
for the Asian community in the position
you're in we're doing fine we got China
we're gonna take over the world soon
what do you need me to do
a couple of us died during the pandemic
it was worth it
oh holy [ __ ] we're doing fine what are
you doing to contribute to the Asian
narrative in a positive way go get ready
for those questions I'm showing us that
we can have a sense of humor instead of
all being stuck up like Mega Shark
comments yeah if you had to be any other
race what would it be
um you can say white black he says black
black is like the highest risk highest
reward either you're like [ __ ] Will
Smith or you're not or you're just being
not Will Smith is a disaster yes it's a
disaster I mean not Will Smith like uh
Dion Cole or yeah
we gotta get Dion
start her up again oh my God
what's what's one of the cool pieces of
advice Joe Rogan has ever given you
about like your comedy you end it with a
joke
yeah we have to We're not gonna end it
has Joe Rogan giving you a watch yeah
yeah but we did um but yeah I mean the
coolest piece of advice he gave me was
uh
uh well it wasn't really advice but
after one of my sets he was like good
job man I was like thank you he's like
yeah you're funny I was like thank you
yeah that's the most important thing
you're funny and you got it so I mean
that was just like from my hero just
being like you have the intangible dude
he seems pretty intelligent you know you
kind of have to be funny to be a
comedian yeah for sure
I know I mean if you're doing comedy for
so long you kind of forget you're like I
gotta remember my jokes I gotta gel my
hair and wear a nice shirt my hair that
would be funny when's when's the last
time you cried
uh probably when I was watching a movie
um
probably uh the last movie that I like
uh saw was like uh
God damn uh it's like our father's
generation or our father's time is like
this Korean movie about it's like
Forrest Gump except super depressing
it's Korean Forest Forrest Gump was kind
of happy-go-lucky
some things jump up and lick me when was
the last time you uh
when was the last time that you cried
that you came
or cried that you came or came that you
cry came that you cried that's right
that's what it is yeah
uh I mean I think I was like tired and I
was like yawning and I got like a little
tear in my eye and then I can't I guess
and then you can't and then you came
what was the last uh what was the last
porno you searched uh for or what's the
last thing you typed in your search bar
4.0 uh Japanese shrimp
massage
what's that Japanese it's like a drug
like a like a aerosolized drug that
makes women don't worry oh really what
though is that what the shrimp party
does it work or is it like people think
it works where can I buy something
pretty effective huh where can I buy
some I don't know that's a good question
that's what all the comments are it's
just like
it's just like nobody figured it out
it's like Flex tape though where I see
it work only in the commercials and then
in real life I don't see a lot of
commercials I'm trying to slap it on
something I see a lot of users who are
like I'm so happy about Flex tape yeah
just see the commercial
is it like that yeah maybe it's just
like Patchouli oil or like a goop
product a good product my uncle swears
by emu oil
he says that it occurs the arthritis my
mom loves emu oil see they love it old
people are great do you do you feel like
your parents are proud of you yeah I
think they're proud that I'm not like
dead I think they didn't have very high
hopes so they look at it more of like a
glass shaft yeah I think like hey at
least you're alive and yeah not doing
crime yeah
we would have been good crime friends I
I think so I think we need a purpose
like some people just need like dig a
ditch okay but I need to know like why
and what's it for and like if I'm
stealing it's like I'm trying not to get
caught and trying to make money it's
like like yeah I need a purpose what
what is the last illegal thing that you
did allegedly
uh that's a legal thing I did was
probably like uh well I got caught
shoplifting when I was in college do you
ever steal for fun just yeah yeah not
anymore but I used to I just feel like
shoplifting is like how kids steal if
you want to be an adult you get picked
up behind a computer
and you know get hired at a bank and
steal for real
what's one last thing you want to say to
all the fans out there all the Asian
people that you want them to follow you
yeah I'm one of you support me like if
you don't support me like like who are
you gonna support some random white
comedian yeah no more whites they don't
really do that no more whites they don't
do that some random like there's enough
foreign